[Musique]
une fois le déguisement fait vous allez
sûrement partir pour la chasse aux
bonbons
il ne vous manque qu'un objet
indispensable pour frapper pour les
frapper à la porte des voisins le sac à
friandises
mélanie vous savez comment fabriquer un
an fabrique un même ont une quinzaine de
minutes de minutes à peu près leur pour
mon sac moi j'ai choisi de faire une
chauve souris où j'en ai même fait
d'horizon pas tout à fait la même
elle peut-être mais vous pouvez aussi
faire une citrouille les narines et
pourquoi pas un fantôme la base de toute
manière est toujours la même
vous changerez juste les couleurs du
papier et les décorations donc il nous
faut une paire de ciseaux de la colle un
crayon et une agrafeuse est une forme
ronde pour créer le sac parce qu'en
fonction de la taille du sac
vous pouvez prendre un bol un vase un
plat moi j'ai choisi carrément un
couvercle de boîte à gâteaux et j'ai
aussi choisi de travailler que du papier
à dessin
mais pourquoi pas utilisé du tissu alors
pour commencer j'ai coupé en deux maps
feuille on l'a vu tout à l'heure j'ai
aussi fait le couvercle avec le
couvercle de la boîte à gâteaux j'ai
dessiné le contour du sac ne fait pas le
rond complet puisque la partie plate
vous permettra de faire l'ouverture et
vous découpez les deux formes on vient
de le voir aussi à l'écran vérifiez bien
par contre quel son égal parce que après
ça vous permet de former le sac sans
oublier de créer lens qui nous permettra
de le porter ou est lancée elle doit se
mettre en même temps que les deux les
deux parties mais il suffit juste là
aussi de découper une bande de papier ou
de tissus moi j'ai choisi du blanc pour
changer mais vous pouvez rester dans le
tournoi pour que tous tiennent plusieurs
possibilités une colle qui tient très
bien des agrafes comme sur les images
mais vous pouvez aussi coudre fait
mordre un peu plus de temps et de
patience mais c'est tout à fait
réalisable sur le papier à dessin moi je
les fais sur un des deux modèles
et on termine par le plus amusant
forcément la déco et bien sûr pour faire
une belle chose sourit il faut lui faire
des yeux une jolie bouche ne voulait
surtout pas les dents ou là aussi j'ai
décidé de tout faire avec du papier
blanc une tête les petites notes de
couleurs c'est avec des feutres un petit
coup de colle une fois de plus et la
finition les ailes on les voit il faut
les découper sur des chutes de papier ça
fait quelques arbres ou des là aussi où
l'école à l'arrière du sac et voilà moi
je suis prête pour aller sonner aux
portes de mes voisins et ne pas oublier
surtout la fameuse phrase indispensable
un bonbon ou un sort merci mélanie pour
cette idée de sacs à bonbons pour
compléter notre déguisement